you new efforts now to help minimize the
homeless problem in the valley today
catholic charities gave us a tour of its
renovated emergency night shelter for
men now that facility is filled with new
amenities to help get those back on the
streets back on their feet christian
casadas is in our newsroom with how this
project will help that's right guys
catholic charities of southern nevada
tells us they do their very best every
single day to help those in need get
back on their feet with a variety of
services but if they if needed the
emergency night shelter for men is
available and now with a new look
it's sad to see the people out on the
street for the last six months edward
williams has been calling the streets of
las vegas his home and he's not alone as
of february of this year the census
revealed about 5 600 homeless men and
women in southern nevada it's hard it
really is i mean
once you get to help you've got to find
some place that
will accept you and you know oh i'm
homeless well we don't want you because
you're homeless that is where catholic
charities of southern nevada is stepping
in with a renovated emergency night
shelter for men to help them get off the
streets the great thing about those
primary needs that we have of food and
shelter is it allows our case managers
to get in touch with people and find out
where they're at and then get it get
them back to being sustainable the
project has been underway for the last
year and a half which includes a
renovation of their 400 beds phone
charging lockers fresh paint and new
plumbing this campus is a little over 20
years old and as you can imagine with
the thousands of people that we serve
here each and every day that it gets
worn out the 2022 census state 52
percent of the total homeless population
is white and single 51 percent are
unsheltered and over the last seven
years the numbers are rising my wife's
here we were separated i'm trying to get
her back that's one of the reasons i'm
trying to find an apartment for this 62
year old veteran from indiana the
renovated shelter along las vegas
boulevard and owens he says is a
blessing all the homeless really need is
just to know that somebody's out there
that cares for them
well southern nevada has a variety of
resources for our homeless population
from the shelters to food assistance now
there are ways you at home can help if
you see a homeless encampment in your
neighborhood and of course we have
information on that on our website right
now eightnewsnow.com christian cassette
is live local now